I was accused of transphobia me a trans
man it's like the audacity so what they
did and I have the videos from this so I
tweeted this I said a bunch of a bunch
of my volleyball teammates played in a
tournament today and they were trans
people in it they've made it to England
no now this dude emails me and says I
see your member volleyball England has a
transgender policy which you agreed to
abide by through your membership you
have breached this policy thus also
breaching the volleyball England code of
conduct I have been appointed to
investigate this manner I ask that you
respond to the alleged breach within
seven days by the 20th I think today is
the 20th actually it's 21st